I'm just messing with this kid who's
number one [ __ ] guy in the world
I was like you can just DM day me he's
like yo that's my [ __ ] favorite guy I
was like that's what's up
you got your prospective
[Applause]
[Music]
sitsit how are you that hook that call
brought people value man split flat try
not to like worry about it because it's
like dinner that can't be motivated in
me but then I got my mom so when you go
back to school like that like your mom's
in the middle so what let me talk to you
about yeah
now what me wrong come in I'm on
vacation okay you're coming here you're
spending one day here you're coming here
you're coming to vaynermedia one day I'm
gonna put you with the crew I need to
get you in rewatched until you how old
are you again yeah I mean honestly you
got do me a huge favour my man like the
serendipity of us being here together
you need to realize how lucky you are
for being this young like all that
pressure we talked about on the call
like I know your mom watching do this
I'm sure you're seeing everybody else do
that dude you're gonna live another
twenty-one years your whole life and
you'd still be younger than me that's
real and once you wrap your head around
that shaking it's so good is there
anything you love to do because I really
you know how people talk about do what
you love and everyone's like yeah
whatever what the [ __ ] how am I gonna
make money the reality is what the way
the Internet is it's getting weird like
not that it's so easy but like when
people like I can't find my passion or I
can't do it a lot I'm always like well
what do you like like like like to me I
wish more people realize that if they
love video games and they can play
fifteen hours a day then either you
could become an eSports player that's
hard that's like getting into the league
but you could start a [ __ ] Instagram
podcasts and YouTube around it that's
the next one that's what happened with
me and crazy his back in 2011 I was deep
into the gaming community
but it's just I was just like I can't
make money in that yeah that's what
happened man I was like you know that's
what you know that you know that's what
always happens can't make money in rock
and roll
can't make money and hip-hop can't make
money in videogames Cammie and then you
can that's the biggest advice I give
kids is like if you're 16 right now and
you love something and everybody tells
you there's no money in it
that's because there's no money in it
today there might be money in it in ten
years is there anything I can help you
with well honestly I just wanna know
like how can I just make sure I'm being
solid with myself that's good like I'm
trying to be an aspiring artist music
music and so for me is I don't have I
don't have all the tools yet so I'm just
trying to work everyday like time are
you producer you an artist artist I'd
and you've heard this for me I would
literally [ __ ] DM every [ __ ] music
producer in Manhattan and be like yo I
got 15 hours for you for free if ill
mine gives you 15 hours for you to like
get his coffee and do [ __ ] if he just
says yes cuz on that I mean look what
the [ __ ] are you doing here I said yes
for no [ __ ] reason I do a lot of calls
people don't get it like just one yes if
you want to be [ __ ] in the music
business hit up everybody in the music
business in New York and when you have
nothing to give you have your time to
give my big thing is but if you love
music so much isn't that a good use of
15 hours imagine being in studio
learning how to produce and Dave East is
in the booth you'd be like that's fresh
right right so you'd be like this is
fresh it does I assume it doesn't feel
like work for you
it's what you love you my point it was
extra I hadn't work now it's when you
get to do right it steps right you got
to do this eight to midnight right yes
sir right and then your mom saying get a
real job
and it's real [ __ ] here's a very similar
like everybody's got the same [ __ ]
there's somebody that they love by the
way could be your girlfriend your
boyfriend your grandmother somebody who
who sees the world different and thinks
people should do something that they
think is right and that's the thing
that's the problem because like I want
to do this but it's just like I'm
hearing go to school or take a trade a
massage I want to make music let's do
that at 30 21 you should be taking risks
around your happiness you can get a real
job at 30 and still be a [ __ ] kid and
that's the number one things who I was
just like if anything now it'll work
with DVDs of any hey eight big cuz I
that's the only person I feel that is
rou with the whole music industry
Heidi operas like so you should take DM
Dave East and be like yo I will work 10
hours a week for you for free pick up
your [ __ ] clothes I don't give a [ __ ]
I want to break into the music business
and I know the number one thing that I
have to give you is my blood you go on
Instagram you go to DBS account and you
DM him like
knowing you don't ask you don't get and
you when you're hitting somebody up
right when you're hitting somebody up -
when you're hitting somebody up -
[ __ ] give them value then you're
getting value right like you know like
it's not like you're asking for
something you're trying to give value
you know like that's how I see it like
that that's just how I see it you're not
annoying if you're like yo I will give
you ten hours of my time D Brock hit me
up four times and was like yo I will I
will you know I will make a free video
for you and on the [ __ ] you know on
the more time I said yes and you never
know when yesterday his assistant quit
bro you're sitting in this room on
[ __ ] putting your phone number into
an Instagram live then we had a pic the
[ __ ] phone number call you have a
conversation that compelled me to invite
you here you're sitting here cuz I know
how many people are feeling the exact
same way and you and I combined can help
somebody but I wanted to start with you
cuz you're here it's real life listen
you should come through again I'm gonna
go to my next [ __ ]
you should come through again listen to
me start by just [ __ ] giving people
free time people that you want to be
close to
I mean it's funny that we just randomly
pick babies put like he's the best he's
a good kid to him up I was trying to get
him yeah that would've been great what
up family
I was just mixed I'm just messing with
this kid who's number one [ __ ] guy in
the world say what's up I was telling
this kid I was like yo like if you want
to get into the music game just DM the
person you love the most and just offer
[ __ ] value I was like you could just I
was like you can just DM Davies he's
like yo that's my [ __ ] favorite guy I
was like that's what's up
yeah I'm looking forward to this week
you been good
oh man I'm running for this next meeting
I'll catch up with you later you New
York until what Brian or Thursday or
whatever product all right I might hit
you up I mean whether it's a beast or
Diddy or [ __ ] 2 Chainz if you hit up
people you want to [ __ ] with and just
like yo I'm hungry I got 10 hours for
you I'll come in and build a crate I'll
[ __ ] like you understand
that's all you need is one yes you give
them what they want like you don't have
anything to give yet other than grunt
your two hours but interns become CEOs
all the time learn the game you know all
right let's do it
[Music]
tell me everything
give me I mean obviously I know a lot
from just living in life but give me the
State of the Union of the crew and like
whether you guys are up to and like how
I can help
well I'm getting it to the internet now
I got out when I got out of prison and
one was that exactly
Oh nine okay after how long uh 20 years
I found out about you about four months
ago
you know because I wasn't I don't watch
TV I don't I'm thrilled anybody knows
who I am so I get it the same way I I'm
in such a cocoon there's so much [ __ ]
yeah and it was so fragment and now you
could be the biggest rapper the biggest
kid on tick-tock the big I mean
athlete like the world so for it's not
1984 anymore where everybody knew the
same people right and then after I
started to hear you speak and I was like
[ __ ] this guy says what I'm thinking why
the way I think you know the way I ran
my drug empire the way that I do
everything right now this guy does it
and I started telling a Sam one of my
guys that I would like to meet this guy
you know I would like to sign on and
talk to him I'm glad we're here and he's
the one that introduced me tell you I
was like check out Gary Vee someone put
me on to you right yeah you know I
showed him the video
he was like scared things just like me
who sings just like me and like
beginning I was like Rick I'm gonna
clapping minute listen I'm so on the
record on like this is all the same [ __ ]
I just believe it I so much sense to me
I don't have every T and I crossed of
your career but anybody that's
successful in flipping and organizing
anything whether it's garage saling
drugs sneakers business it's it's the
same mechanics and I'll be honest with
you the Internet actually is creating a
system that leans more towards like I'm
a street kid I was a DNF student it was
like I didn't sell drugs but I like
baseball cards or limit like it's all
the same [ __ ] and the Internet's making
it more valuable for us non students
than the students and so I actually
think the greatest generation of what
has historically been the have-nots is
coming because this equalizes everything
and then what takes over is the way you
and I think because now you're going
into intuition human behavior we're this
close to being psychologists it's true
[Music]
yeah trap I want to can I taste the wine
I literally have not tasted the Rose ah
yeah [ __ ] the alumni programs here
like this is I know there's [ __ ] the
alumni here it's [ __ ] it's a party
are you it's great to see you yeah
pulling it dude I'm so excited right now
no this is literally first time I'm
having your wine I blended it and I
couldn't we birthed it but I haven't
seen my child yet all right this is
literally me tasting empathy rose' for
the first time ever ever let's go
good ohmic you handsome man walked at
this
[Music]
we're deep [ __ ] we really nailed it I'm
like this is that's why everyone likes
it so here you are you're you've been
successful by all accounts I personally
believe that you're about to get really
successful because I think you're
patient and hungry and doing the right
things and even if the global economy
takes a step back I just I can see it I
know exactly who you're gonna be at 71
and I'm looking forward to having more
stories with you but you're sitting here
and telling everybody the 72 hours I
spent with this person shaped you know
you had your natural DNA the hustler
immigrant [ __ ] fine I just wish more
people heard you and this is why I'm
making the big to-do here seventy-two
hours now all of you who I tell in your
20s when you're doing dick [ __ ] nothing
with your [ __ ] life when I tell you
to spend two hours a day on your couch
doing dick [ __ ] nothing and diem
everybody you admire and say to them
I've got [ __ ] time your busiest [ __ ]
I will [ __ ] do anything
eat [ __ ] for fifteen hours a week for
free for you a once in a blue moon
somebody says yes and that will change
your life happen to you
happen a d-roc like happen to Andy this
is real thank you guys for watching hope
you guys are super well hope you enjoyed
it I thought that was being a good one
it was a real good I appreciate that I
appreciate brother
we're at a maid in New York Pizza with a
little bit of a meet-up we hit up a
bunch of influencers new location I'm an
investor in a ton Sugarman's place good
dude
excited to see a bunch of people that I
haven't met who follow me on the gram a
bunch of the pizza say what's up hello
hi
[Music]
Stephanie what's up baby taking full
advantage of today girl advantage maybe
joke Gary Baroni though this place is
amazing I never cease it up with so much
pepperoni on the spice it's true it's
like it's like it's like it's like the
pizzas the act the topic to the action
it's like pepperoni with some pizza it's
true it's true my rickety rock in the
back d-roc you servin it's making
contact and I know you touched on this
level you're everything
I really understand the hearts
meditating when when the next cycle of
pain I think most of the [ __ ] that I'm
spitting gets really understood the next
time we have economic pains because even
right now I'm starting to feel public
backlash a little bit that I'm spending
a little too much happiness and people
are sitting on me a little bit about
like no no you to make money I'm like
cool that's fine right now because the
economy's great pick me up when [ __ ]
hits the fan and everybody's in trouble
so I think a lot of this will get
cleaned up and synthesized when the
[ __ ] when the when the economy gets
touched brands don't have money to give
influencers money people are naive
because they're young and having looked
through a cycle even you at 34 and you
know you're just what do we use so gun
like you know you haven't lived it you
haven't lived with like the market
collapses what I'm most worried about is
people have played up something that
they may have to take a step back and
it's gonna hurt more than they're
willing to feel the hurt and I don't
know what they're gonna do
the biggest mistake influencers make is
they pandas in a platform not to their
own happiness yeah you know what is
gonna work and get likes and you'll do
that over what you actually care about
yeah I know that's I just I'm brought
back and don't do that
[Music]
number three number one mistake that
influencers make is they pander to the
platform not to their habits it is the
number one safety post about something
in a good grass that's that we get
different rapport so I to be cool are we
trying to go to every or you put out
something that you know gets 10,000
likes instead of something that's going
to be meaningful to your life yeah but I
mean we just want to get to the fire
photo yeah it's not making you happy at
the end but you have to post [ __ ] that
makes you happy not what you think is
gonna get good engagement because then
you became [ __ ] sucked up in the
machine I did no [ __ ] no and you can't
let that happen
[Music]
[Laughter]
be smart otherwise this is going to get
worse and worse being the Ryan Seacrest
of
that's my goal that's my dream
I have a real I have a real thought
about that I think what you could do is
disproportionately try to bring people
value so like I don't think people
understand how much leverage there is in
giving so figure out what the 500 most
important people are in sports whether
it's the people that run the cup
whether it's do you know you know Erica
the CEO barstool I haven't met her yet
but my agent
I just got sent me an email right now
here's the thing Jackie that everybody
[ __ ] up say go and meet Erica and what
happens everybody said the mindset of
like what can you do at what Erica what
can you do for me right right how do you
Erica as a CEO barstool how mu becomes a
Ryan Seacrest's Awards right what you
need to figure out is hey Erica the [ __ ]
can I do for you know the worst thing to
do is what can you do for me okay the
next worst thing is here's how I can
help you because that's you giving on
more time on your terms the best thing
you can do is hey Erica let me listen to
you what can I do for you bronies are
legit have you had one yeah doing a few
people I want because I go to the
bathroom I tell us you we good
yeah we're all good reporter of course
all right Jase this is it I got no
[ __ ] clothes like I'm [ __ ]
finished it's a good day got a lot of
[ __ ] done you got when you [ __ ] eat
in eat some [ __ ] pizza yeah
[Music]
[Music]